but also sometimes I worry that perhaps
we're too stupid to understand these
complex problems and we come up with
[Music]
it so a woman is getting surgery right
I'm surgery right what's a favorable
surgery for a woman
uh when they make them a little bit
smarter yeah through surgery I try I try
I hope so so she's in there for to give
a what's called a a Caesar salad
um section cesarean thank you cesarean
section is it called with croutons old
timing because it's a thousand island
it's an old-time section that's what it
said right with the anchovies dude yes
you know they make Caesar with anchovies
she's giving birth to a baby right and
then they have to use this surgical tool
which I don't know if you guys have ever
seen one of these suckers before they're
called uh Alexis retractors whoa you
ever heard of one of these little
suckers space condom it goes like in
your body and holds you open whoa while
you pull the they can like reach in
there and I'll do all kinds of oh so is
it kind of like keep all of your other
like meat and organs like out of the way
so you can pull it out is that what
makes it a cesarean whoa I don't know I
call it a Caesar salad thing a second
ago that's freaking crazy I didn't know
they did that a Neapolitan C-section so
the thing about this is that's kind of
crazy
is that this thing is 17 centimeters or
6 inches in diameter oh and the device
was left entirely inside of her body
after they got the baby out they dropped
the device in and sewed it right up it
could probably be like a car shade you
know it's like this but if you
yeah it was this small so maybe it was
like maybe it was in retraction but on
the side yeah so you didn't know it
could have been in return and then they
sewed it and it popped back no sounds
like something that happened at geyser
so a couple couple months go by and
months he's having chronic pain and she
goes for several checkups and they're
like you're good stop freaking out it's
all in your head lady yeah why don't you
just have a baby or something you'll
feel better
your [__] drama queen they called our
drama queen yeah yeah drama dream and
she said the pain got so severe that she
had to go to the hospital's emergency
department and that poor lady discovered
the device on a CT scan bro how long did
it take them to like months lawsuit
yeah hope she rakes it in dude the New
Zealand health and his disability
commissioner found that this um Hospital
Health Board was in breach of the code
of patient rights
and they're being reprimanded they also
claim that a nurse who was in her 20s
attended to the woman during her
cesarean had failed to exercise
reasonable skill and care towards the
patient they were careless uh yeah bro
if you leave something in someone's body
dude this happens like a bunch of times
a year that's pretty careless goofy
doofy dude it's super mega believe like
scissors
yeah gloves scalpels when Geo got her uh
meniscus surgery they had to use a
Sharpie and confirm with like the doctor
and the nurse and like Jill like this is
the one right and everyone's like this
and then they like draw like up with the
Sharpie is it because we got too many
sleepy doctors and then when they're
done they're like hey where'd we put the
[__] Sharpie
where's the cap
don't read the notes
yeah yeah that happens every year too
also due to doctor's handwriting a
certain amount amount of people die why
don't they write like that I don't know
hieroglyphics
yeah and in the the pharmacist goes oh I
know exactly what that is [__] iPads
dude I remember I was getting like acne
medication when I was like 15 years old
and like literally I just had like my
mom and me were handing the note over
it's just like a straight line it's like
a straight line with a little tiny
little squiggly with a straight line
looks like the heart monitor thing with
the little blue and like the person's
like oh yeah they know somehow yeah I
don't know how the system yeah what what
what's the reason for that stereotype
what if they all write the same squiggly
shitty way like something that we don't
understand
some kind of language that's their Morse
colors yeah like that's their cursive I
think they're just doing so many of them
and the shape is the same oh just the
they don't give a [__] it's writing a
lot all day yeah it's true because they
have to do it like all day long it's
probably not worth and get paid [__]
tons for it the same amount whether it's
a line or a whole illegible name dude
because when you see some doctors they
you just feel like I shouldn't be here
because they make you feel like all
right what's the [__] is your problem
you know it's true yeah let's even go to
the doctor then why am I gonna go I do
judge the doctor like if I'm going to a
doctor for like a actual physical like
athletic injury and the doctor comes in
he's like
okay tell me what's going on with your
knee again I'm like oh this guy don't
[__] because you don't even [__] walk
do you I'm out of here have you just
like pulled his back out that morning so
inconsiderate Bart nah there's a shot
here dude you know full compassion you
know what kind of doctors they are when
you walk in they might be a former
Olympian or something no get me a doctor
with some [__] shape breaks through
the wall oh my God yeah Nick is hype
Manning for like maybe the thinnest
argument I've ever seen Bart make and
[__] like yeah this guy got muster on
his [__] lab coat dude you already
know dude yeah you know so [__] the
board also had to write write a written
apology to the woman
um and they are revising their policies
as part of the surgical count of like
what you know what we have to keep track
of items policy they just need the
[__] janitor's keychain you know how
they have the key if you let go it goes
right to where it is so if you got that
[__] tube thing as soon as you're
done you let go
never leave anything in there Sharpies
[__] scalpel everything solve it with
the little janitor's keychain I just
feel like that might not work but I
think that would be imagine having a
scalpel he's not talking about God I
know what a [__] General keychain
maybe you don't get what I'm saying
no fool you live in the cool world you
don't know [__] cool geek [__] first
of all that's a bad example you should
think about like the ID name cards
wow that's similar but it's the same
idea wait that's like only like plastic
and paper you said you want to put a
[__] scalpel on that imagine like
using this gobble janitor's keychain
holds all kinds of metal and [__] James
keychain can hold all the items of the
universe
so this is
no the one with the retractable cable
talking about the bungee ones well it
has a retractable you guys are on the
same page right now this is bothering me
it's a great idea though thank you why
do you think so many people just leave
things in because they don't have the
janitor's keychain with the bungee
like why do you think that if we were to
talk to a nurse right now what do you
think the number one excuse would be
well we gotta probably think about like
the the ratio of accidents right so
maybe it's like it happens all the time
but there's like millions of operations
so it only happens like a thousand times
maybe it's not a lot you know what I
mean they're like room for error but
don't they do like a check of like do we
have all the equipment that we use for
the surgery afterwards they're usually
supposed to have one other person it's
like a checks and balances system to
hand them the thing right so if like one
person forgot the fact that no one else
caught it is a little weird plus like
maybe this surgeon just did like an
18-hour operation and it's like this
emergency just happened so they run over
and they're like yeah yeah or it's just
like where's our big tube thing like
where is it yeah where's our
one two three we only have one
boxes yeah
doctors out there just let us know in
the comments why you guys [__] up so
much yeah let's not worry this [__] up I
think they're just sleeping and
apologize yeah and if you guys are
medical like healthcare workers [__] on
the people that you've seen that have
done really because okay what about this
children's placemat okay yeah you know
how there's a [__] placemat ball goes
here oh yeah spoon goes here well if
you're gonna do [__] baby delivery
get the baby delivery place mat it tells
you okay put all the tools here so now
once you're done you roll it up see if
it if you filled in all the holes and
then the whole placement goes back on
your bungee janitor
yes all this [__] goes flying oh [__]
goes flying holy [__] we've solved why
did we we attached the menu we didn't
attach all the items
I thought it was gonna be like the
tablecloth trick
they could velcro them
that's not bad either hey like in space
dude in space I got objects flying all
around their heads they don't grow that
[__] to the walls and stuff label it we
gotta label things we got to answer this
here at JK also stop leaving scissors
inside of people like why do you even
drop them inside of someone just put it
on the tray so easy I would imagine
you're using scissors a lot you know
what I mean so it's like you can't leave
that in someone's person what if they
get so comfortable with it that they're
just like talking like it's just regular
driving and they're just hanging out and
then like things just get placed it
comes apart and they need to do the
[__] duct tape their mouth stop
talking yeah before they do this shut up
dude because you know how much how much
you're charging me for this [__]
surgery you guys better be [__]
perfect you guys better shut the [__] up
they can't talk to each other because
everybody's a duct tape yeah the poor
mouth breather is out there man
dreamers
that's the best [__] idea it's a
great idea
but also sometimes I worry that perhaps
we're too stupid to understand these
complex problems and we come up with
it
Steve come on I know it's all Steve day
but uh relax either that here's another
one okay okay you have a big bright
light in top on top of the surgery table
right I've seen it okay get a [__]
junkyards giant magnet thing the thing
that can go with the [__] car
right that way when you're done just let
go
yeah this was doing surgery like he's
cutting meat yeah you [__] do
whatever and as soon as you're done rips
through their bodies and then all the
Staples I hope they don't have any
feelings or anything like my metal hip
powerful man
the whole surgery their heads just
[Music]
lifting off the table yeah my mom has a
metal rod in her leg from when she broke
her leg she'd [__] lose that thing
quick oh yeah
they just turn it off dude yeah maybe we
should stick to the janitor's keychain
away magnet 1.0 I'm sure like 5.0 will
be really good yeah selective metal
magnetism yeah just in that one area
okay okay this might this might work
[Music]
oh